i'm off the grid for august but cnn is
still a propaganda network
we should be focused on how do we solve
these problems so that when we have the
midterms in a car election we have
our elections are fine
we have chad there's fraud in our
election system and and if if people
don't acknowledge that then that becomes
part of the problem you are the you are
the former acting absolutely acting
secretary of homeland security and
you're spreading doubt and fear and it's
not doubt about about our election
process
these are some no facts these are
alternative facts
jim you're making
you're saying there's no draw i didn't
want the election
are you saying there's no fraud in our
election system of course there are some
episodes absolutely that's what i'm
talking about bill barr let's talk about
that said this was bs why not accept it
move on
jim this is what i'm talking about there
are a number of irregularities
illegalities and fraud when we talk
about our election to alter the outcome
look i don't i certainly don't know that
i'm not in charge of that but what i
would say if there's
even if there's a small amount that is
worth coming together and trying to
solve that at a national level and at a
state level so that we can get past this
so that we have some integrity in our
elections well we need to have integrity
but we also need to have integrity among
officials who work in the government and
who have left the government uh who will
tell the american people and i think we
need to have it we certainly need to
have some integrity by those reporting
the news as well and we do have that
integrity but we expect that of our
elected leaders and people who work
under them because you can't continue to
sow these seeds of doubt about american
democracy it's simply
failing the american people to continue
to lead them down this path of lies
so it's not lies jim i'm happy to go
through everything that i i just said
and to go into detail i think when you
deny the facts when you deny the facts
that there has been some amount of fraud
now i can't tell you how much
uh there has been some fraud there's
been illegalities we see it state after
state after state we haven't even talked
about zuckerberg we haven't even talked
about the number of things that occurred
it sounds it sounds you it sounds like
you've watched one too many conspiracy
films about the 2020 election no i'm
actually i'm actually reading the news